- You only live once so...
- Today we're going to
play do you know your
favorite artist's real name?
The sudden death pie to the face quiz.
I'm going to give each
person 10 seconds to answer.
If they get it right, they
can eat this delicious pie.
If they get it wrong, they've got to slam
their face into this pie.
(tense music)
- I don't really like pies but I do think
that I'm a master of trivia.
- [Voiceover] His stage name is Bono.
Is his real name John
O'Dwyer or Paul Hewson?
- Oh man.
Is it John O'Dwyer,
sounds very Irish to me,
the O in there.
So I'm going to go with John O'Dwyer.
- [Voiceover] Wrong.
- Aw, man.
- [Voiceover] His stage
name is The Weeknd.
Is his real name Gabriel Rodriguez-Lopez
or Abel Tesfaye?
- Abel Tesfaye because
he dates Bella Hadid
who I'm in love with.
I get to keep this pie.
Maybe.
- [Voiceover] Correct.
- Yes!
- I'm like suddenly so nervous and tense.
My mouth is dry.
- [Voiceover] Her stage name is Rihanna.
Is her real name Robyn
Fenty or Anna Rebele?
- There's no way that Rihanna's last name
is Rebele and she didn't make that part
of her stage name.
Rebele is too cool of a name.
She'd just be like,
"Yo, my name is Rebel."
Or like Lil' Rebel, that
would be my rap name.
- [Voiceover] Correct.
- Does that mean I don't have
to smash a pie in my face?
I get to eat the pie.
- [Voiceover] The pie is yours.
- I kind of want to smash
it in my face anyway.
I've never smashed a pie in my face.
Is that okay?
I love you, Rihanna.
(rock music)
That was good.
- I know musicians' names
because I like the realness.
I like the truth.
- [Voiceover] Her stage
name is Taylor Swift.
Is her real name Taylor
Swift or Taylor Callahan?
(tense music)
- It's Taylor Swift.
Right?
- [Voiceover] Final answer?
- Yeah, that's Taylor Swift.
- [Voiceover] Correct.
- Cool.
- (beeps) I'm scared.
Okay, I'm ready.
(laughs)
- [Voiceover] His stage
name is Kendrick Lamar.
Is his real name Kendrick
Duckworth or Lamar Kendall?
- Oh man, Duckworth, I
don't know that I know
anybody with the last name Duckworth.
So, I'm thinking that I'm going to go with
the second one.
- [Voiceover] Wrong.
(laughs)
- What? What?
Duckworth?
This is (beeps) up.
This is so (beeps) up.
(laughing)
It's inside my nose.
- If I were a singer, I'd probably go
with a fake name too.
I'd be like, "Andromeda."
- [Voiceover] Andromeda Cornfeld.
- Andromeda Cornfeld, yeah,
I'd keep the Cornfeld.
I'd keep the Jewish part of my name
but change Zach, I'd
be Andromeda Cornfeld.
(creaking)